hello everyone some of you may have
heard the news already but in case you
haven't yesterday sometime around 9:00
9:30 p.m. Central European Time my
channel reached 200,000 subscribers now
you all know what that means it means a
very nice stream a nicely chess arena
some some prizes some giveaways some
chairs jokes of course some guests on
the stream and of course a very nice
style game now I wanted to show this
game plenty of times I was tempted to
show it but I I always thought you know
it's it's better to wait better to wait
you know better let the channel grow and
then even more and more people can see
this game so I mean I could wait a bit
longer but I think now's as good time as
any to show it it's a game from 1987 it
was played in a tournament in Reykjavik
here at Michael tile with the white
pieces faces Johan here after Sun and
although I couldn't find a photo of the
two of them playing I did find a photo
that the two of them shared with three
other very strong grandmasters so I will
use this photo to show it to you there's
chapters on install on the right but I'm
also going to use this for a photo
challenge you are more than welcome to
try and identify the remaining three
grandmasters on this photo so best of
luck to everyone and now a lot of you
may never have heard of johani Hart
arson but in 1987 he was in fact a very
strong player he was in top form as he
did when the inter zonal tournament he
tied for first place and then he
qualified for the 1988 candidates
candidates tournament where he
eliminated Viktor Korchnoi from the
tournament and then in the quarterfinals
lost to Anatoly Karpov and here I did I
did find that these are these this is
fides reading list from January 1989 so
it's after the candidates tournament at
there you can see that he after stone
johan is a number 11 in the world
regarding the the rating and the Michael
Tao is number 19 in the world so just I
wanted to put that a little bit in the
perspective but this is played in 1987
where he actor son is a young
Grandmaster he just received his
Grandmaster title in 1985 so already
has his title for two years and he's
rated somewhere around two to two to
twenty five hundred and fifty so that
being said let's check out this very
nice game towel opens the game with E 4
we have E 5 Knight to f3 and the night
assist almost forgot to be 5 of course
the real opus and it's very interesting
this game will be first 20 movies are
pretty much aligned from the book but
then the game really really you know
opens up we have a 6 more fees defense
Russia pay for Knight to f6
we have castles Bishop to e7 rook to e1
b5 Bishop to b3 or standard theory we
have castles C 3 b 6h 3 nice to a5 from
Bishop to see - and now c5 we have d4 by
tau Queen to see 7/9 d2 we have Bishop
to d7 preparing rook c8 night to f1
preparing night to e3
we have pawn captures pawn captures and
now rook the c8 with tempo immediately
threatening Queen captures the bishop on
c2 we have nice to e3 defending the
bishop and now comes Knight the sefa
Knight to c6 pressuring the defy at the
d4 pawn but also preparing night before
to further pressure the bishop and c2 we
have D 5 by 2 nice to be four and now
Bishop to be one getting the bishop out
of the way and now a5 immediately the
night is very strong one before so of
course top pushes it back if I was
plates to make room for the night and a
692 86 and now before before a very nice
move by tau seemingly offering a pawn
here but not really if you try to care
to grab a pawn here you would lose this
night due to Bishop to d2 trapping it
the night has nowhere to go
even if you defend it Queen c5 defending
at Queen b3 and now the night really
doesn't have anywhere to go
a 6 is guarded by the rook c6 by the
pawn and the d3 by the Bishop of course
and c2 by the Queen Bishop and night and
e3 so this would this would lose you a
piece Harrison goes for g6 we have rush
up to d2
we have a capture some be for a captors
before and a queen to be seven we have
Bishop to d3 now Queen to be seven
notice that sort of sorry about going
back the the rook and Queen are really
controlling the C file nicely but tells
bishops although they look they don't
look really active they are creating a
nice wall here on the C file and the
black can't really use the C file to
exert any pressure so we have Queen to
b7
Bishop to d3 now comes nice to see seven
night - C - and now a nice knife to h5
Bishop to e3 vital and now rook to e8 we
have Queen to d2 are connecting rooks
rook captures on a1 and now rook
captures any one would be an automatic
for pretty much everyone but tau plays
Knight captures on a1 he wants to bring
the nice to be three to a5 and all the
way to c6 but he does allow some nice
counter play by black by doing this and
he has to be very careful here he our
son immediately goes for f5 we have
Bishop to h6 attacking the rook Knight
goes back to g7 and now Knight to b3
talks simply continues with his plan of
bringing the knight to c6 we have F for
not closing up the position knife to a5
Queen to b6 and row now comes rook the
c1 I with the thrill of course Knight to
c6 and then Bishop captures will be
pretty much useless as the rook is
guarding it from c1 rook to 8 and now
first before playing Knight to c8 first
all improves the position Queen to c2
we have nights to e8 and now Queen to b3
we have Bishop to f6 Bishop to f6 is a
good move but pretty much the only move
after tau played Queen to b3 there
really is no good move here for black
although black what is slightly better
you know as he told us control more
space and although there's a really no
threat at the moment okay Knight
captures an e5 followed by d6 could be a
threat but Bishop f6 stops it but there
really is no move you can play here with
the black pieces the bishop has nowhere
to go
the denied
really nowhere to go it can go to h5 but
that's not really as a square you want
to use for your night and not really you
can't really make out a useful plan for
black here so Bishop to f6 preventing
from any Knight captures on e5 ideas now
comes Knight to c6 and now Knight to h5
you do have to try and organize your
pieces somehow so Knight to h5 preparing
Bishop to g7 to at least get rid of tall
strong bishop on e6 as we've said
capturing the knight here doesn't really
make all that much sense D captures and
c6 now comes with check you have to
remove the King Queen e6 is coming and
black is completely shattered here you
can't move the knight it's pinned you
can't move this neither than Queen kept
person if six is coming and there's
really not all that much you can do the
the C pawn is is gonna be pushed so this
would be terrible for black so here
knife to h5 and here tall really starts
here brings out his magic wand and he
starts preparing the stage here tall
plays Queen to b2 and to really
understand Queen to be - you really have
to see what happens and see how far
tells imagination goes here theater
stone of course plays Bishop to g7 as he
did prepared with Knight to h5 italics
changes bishops Bishop captures King
captures and now notice that the Queen
from b2 is not on the same diagonal as
the King and g7 and here you might think
okay it's it's tall he's probably gonna
play Knight captures on e5 and it's game
over
well not really if you play Knight
captures on e5 and D captures only five
Queen captures on e5 with check after
King to g8 there's a really no good way
to continue your attack and you are down
a piece White is still better here but
there's no clear win here after ninety
seven check King f8 the you're really
not achieving much
Queen Queen here Queen here will
completely stop White's attack and
there's really no way to pursue anything
here
white would have to go back and then
black will just move the King back and
say okay well what have you done here
instead here after King to g7 I want you
to pause the video here and try to find
a
nice towel move that top plate in this
game so I will give it a couple of
seconds as usual for those of you who
were able to find it congratulations the
the the magic wand has chosen you and
for those of you who just wanna enjoy
the show here top plate rook to c5
rope to c5 is a very nice move
definitely a tall move and well what's
the idea behind it
first we must ask ourselves the obvious
what happens if D captures on c5 if D
captures on c5 obviously the e5 point is
no longer protected then then comes
Knight F captures only 5 threatening all
sorts of discoveries such as Knight
captures and d7 followed by capturing
the Queen even if you capture with the
Bishop still 97 wins the Queen so here
you would have to move the Queen and
then after Knight captures on d7 with
the check
you'd have to block it then comes Knight
captures on c5 attacking the Queen and
after Queen a1 check which is pretty
much forced Queen captures rook captures
and after King h2 getting out of check
you would get rook to e1 now attacking
the pawn preventing it from being pushed
forward but here tower would be down the
exchange but with d6 it is pretty much
wins the game you have to capture it and
then e 5 wins apiece
you have nice moves captures captures
and here black has black has no
compensation with Knight and Bishop
against the rook another thing another
thing after this rook the c5 you could
say okay I'm not I'm not touching that
what happens if Bishop captures on c6
also not not bad for black but still
rook captures Queen has to move and then
Bishop captures on b5 you just lost a
very important pawn and the black has no
counter play you can exchange Queens
okay but after King moves and rook to be
one rook the c-4 will defend the b4 pawn
the bishop will move and then the b-pawn
will slowly but surely win the game so
you can't really afford that so after up
to c5 he Arthur's don't immediately
played Queen to a6 not not allowing any
discoveries after Knight characters on
e5 here we have rook captures on b5 now
if the rook moves
there will be a discovery towards the
black queen so what do you do here well
if you play bunch of captures on c6
again you get D capture screen captures
and here although the material the
material on the board is equal it's five
points each
it's a passed beep on and it it would be
very hard to stop this point but perhaps
it was it wasn't such a bad idea to try
this and maybe maybe hope for some
passive position that white cannot break
through but ok I have to look to be five
theaters and tried nice to see seven
with the idea that now the rook has to
move but what star played definitely he
a person did not expect here Tao played
rook to b8 what's the idea of rook to b8
well the idea is very simple tal wants
the rook to control the entire last rank
so the king can go back with FA to g8 or
h8 another thing that all did here is
that he opened up a discovered attack
from the bishop to the Queen so now you
have to pretty much two choices you can
either decide to capture the bishop or
you could go for something like Queen to
a3 offer a trade and after Queen
captures King captures attacking the
bishop bishop to f1 still you have the
past be pawn and you're not gonna have
much fun stopping it and if the bishop
captures on c6 i then thought will even
have to pass pawns
so not really an option here here are
some captures the bishop which is the
strongest move recommended by the engine
he plays Queen captures on d3 and now
comes Todd's idea and now you you you
can see that all the variation stall had
to see when he played Queen to be to now
Tao plays Knight see captures on e5
the queen is under attack but also now
the only the only thing that was
standing between the Queen and b2 and
the King and g7 this ePHI pawn is no
longer there capturing it loses
immediately the Queen captures and if I
would check the rook now controls the
entire last rank after we block this
simply Queen e7 check King moves and
after Queen ff8 check King moves Queen
captures on f6 and that there is no
defense against Queen to g5 checkmate or
whatever black plays
so after this night see captors on e5 we
have Queen to d1 check okay King to h2
by tau and now comes rock j1 and all of
a sudden it's actually Harrison who is
threatening mate mate in one with Queen
to h1 checkmate
but here unfortunately for Carter's
Montel has forced checkmate so feel free
to pause the video here and try to find
the the series of move style played that
I made a Harrison resigned in the game
so I will give it a couple of seconds as
usual you know try and try to do it it's
a very nice idea so for those of you who
were able to do it congratulations you
know the magic wand really likes you and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show if you found Knight captures on
b7 with the discovered check the ones
that did not choose you as after King to
h6 black defense now there is no defense
for white against Queen to h1 checkmate
there is no good way to continue the
attack here and white would simply have
to give up the Queen to stop checkmate
and now it's actually tile who doesn't
have compensation for the Queen so after
this rook to a-1 move here towel plate
Knight to g4 and if you found this then
your you have the right idea now black
is without ammo you can start by giving
away material 24 Knight of 6 but those
moves don't really make sense so here
are some place did you only move he
could King to f7 here top late night to
h6 check notice that the King doesn't
have anywhere to go the Queen is
controlling the diagonal the rook is
controlling the last rank and the pawn
is controlling d6 so the only movie
Arthur stone can make is king 37 here
top late night the g8 check and it was
in this position on move 43 that Johan
Harrison resigned the game he did not
wait for King back to f7 and Knight to
g5 which would deliver checkmate notice
it's really a beautiful position the
Queen
ever since thought played Queen B 2 and
that move that we mentioned the Queen
remained there and you know doing
nothing but controlling this diagonal
and not even controlling the dragon
first a couple of moves had to be played
so table would remove the e5 pawn but
to do that he had to give up some
material but is beautiful queen
controlling this diagonal rook
controlling the last rank and the
Knights delivering checkmate a beautiful
position and a beautiful game by the
magician Michael Tao so yeah I wonderful
game and I was really waiting a long
time to show it so I do hope you enjoyed
it it was played in 1987 the Euro I was
born actually so and I did prepare these
are the final standings after the 1987
tournament in Reykjavik tull won second
place as you can see the tournament was
won by Nigel short one full point ahead
of talent Iman and here as you can see
Yohan Carter soon yeah we said it
correctly twenty five hundred and fifty
five rating in 10th place behind 9th
place you will merely voyage so yeah
very nice and for those of you who may
be interested
Johanna Arthur's on it was age 24 then
now he's aged 55 still one of the
strongest grandmasters in Iceland and he
wanted him on the Iceland Championship
five times and the Nordic championship
two times so very nice to my knowledge
he's still doing well so you know it
would maybe it would be a nice idea to
someday get his his perspective of the
game so yeah once again that's the game
I do hope you enjoyed it and now on to
the rules of the giveaway and and about
the stream so as I haven't streamed you
know while I will do a stream today
somewhere around it will be a test
stream like a distress two hours but I
will make a tournament and leeches may
be lasting an hour hour and 15 minutes
just you know to test everything out and
see if I can if I still remember how to
stream so you're all welcome to attend
my tournament but the the real
tournament and the stream will start
tomorrow tomorrow at 1900 or 7:00 p.m.
Central European summer time I will put
all of the important information about
it in the description below so the
tournament will last for the stream will
last for hours as usual first there will
be a two hour
and unleashes it will be Alicia's arena
2 plus O with a prize fund of $1000 and
all of the details about the tournament
will also be there then we're gonna play
some games you're all welcome to
challenge me or I will be joined by an
almighty and a couple of other guests so
your you will be able to play some games
against us as usual you know prepare the
best chess jokes so you know you can
share them with us and we can share them
publicly and hopefully we're gonna we're
gonna have a good time and for the
giveaway I'm of course giving away yet
again two championship chess sets which
will be you know the winners of the
giveaway will be chosen in real time at
the end of my stream or maybe in the
middle we'll see
and also 10/10 Amazon gift cards a value
at $25 each so that's basically it
hope to see you as many of you today in
my test stream but I hope to see really
all of you tomorrow in the real stream
it's the 7 p.m. Central European Time
central brilliant summer time I believe
that's the term so hopefully or
hopefully all of you can make it once
again thank you everyone for helping me
reach this amazing milestone of 200000
subscribers and like I've already
mentioned in my social media hopefully
we will grow even further and you know
together increase our vast knowledge so
I think I've said everything you know
but I will mention everything in the
details so I really hope I mentioned
everything important about this game so
I would like to thank a Gregor ona
William Fusco a Morgan burns and then
O'Hanlon for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank all for
watching and I will see you soon with
another interesting game and you know
the test stream is today do join